it's been about four months since
apple's iphone 13 pro has been out in
the wild and while this is hands down my
favorite iphone update of all time for
various reasons like absolutely insane
battery life and the 120hz promotion
display there are still some issues that
apple hasn't fixed for months for
example we had a ton of complaints from
users concerning the new promotion
display tech and how it doesn't exactly
reach 120 hertz when it seems like it
should and yes in my own testing i did
notice these weird occasional stutters
every now and then but it didn't really
bother me because it didn't happen often
and to be honest i thought it was
because of the way that apple was tuning
the refresh rate to match the speed that
you're scrolling or swiping because
that's exactly what they advertised but
apparently there were some deeper issues
that were causing those stutters for
example it was extremely disappointing
to see that when the iphone 13 pro first
launched 120 hertz mode was not
available for certain animations in
third-party apps and apple even told
developers that they had to make a
special entry in their app to take full
advantage of promotion which is
obviously very annoying but now the new
ios 15.4 update has finally been
released and is jam-packed with some of
the biggest features and updates that
all together fix the iphone 13 pro and
make it a much better value for a lot of
people so what i'm gonna do in this
video is go through all of the awesome
features and changes that came with ios
15.4 and explain why they're such a big
deal like the absolutely awesome new
face id with masks feature which i'll
get into in just a minute but before
that we've got to go through the major
120 hertz pro motion fix that apple has
just added so let's get right into it
apparently there was a core animation
bug that was causing third-party apps to
have issues with full 120 hertz support
and apple has finally fixed it now all
third-party apps automatically get 120hz
animations moving forward without the
software developers having to do
anything at all to make it happen which
is awesome so this now means that we
shouldn't be experiencing those weird
stutters anymore since it'll work more
like the ipad pros which christian selig
tested and confirmed but on the other
hand with animations that aren't that
quick pro motion will still be able to
dynamically go down to 60 fps to help
save battery life compared to the ipad
pro which is basically always stuck on
120 hertz while browsing and scrolling
and only really goes down to as low as
24 hertz while watching videos or movies
so the iphone does work a little bit
differently to help save battery life
and i honestly think it's why the iphone
13 pro max has the best battery life out
of any mainstream smartphone out there
and in my personal experience 120hz
promotion has been one of my all-time
favorite features of this phone so i'm
glad that apple finally addressed those
issues now moving on to by far the most
requested feature people have had for
years apple has finally enabled face id
to work while you are wearing a mask now
this is huge because the pandemic
encouraged everyone to wear masks which
instantly made face id useless for the
past couple of years but finally the new
ios 15.4 update allows you to use face
id while wearing a mask by taking a more
detailed scan of the features around
your eyes now apple does warn that it
isn't as secure and because of that they
require you to be looking directly at
the iphone
as an extra security check but the best
part is that it can still be used for
basically anything like auto filling
your email and password for apps or
websites that use face id and it'll even
allow you to use apple pay and purchase
apps in the app store all while wearing
a mask and if you're wondering what that
pattern is on my mask yes it's little
apple product icons and we have it
available in either white or black if
you're interested in ordering one which
you can do in the merch shelf right
below this video and if you're someone
who wears glasses apple even took care
of that so it seems like people will no
longer have to complain about face id
anymore and because of this new feature
i'm starting to doubt that apple is
going to be adding in-display touch id
to the iphone in the future because in
reality if this new feature works
perfectly fine then there's no real need
for touch id anymore but the only
downside is that apple is requiring that
you either have an iphone 12 or newer
model since that's when they updated
face id to work at a wider angle which
potentially makes it more secure and
this is actually something that john
prosser leaked a long time ago so it's
awesome that we finally have this
feature in our hands but what i'm really
excited about is for when apple finally
gets rid of the notch with the upcoming
iphone 14 pro models which i recently
made a video on if you're interested in
that topic now getting back to ios 15.4
there are actually a few more cool
features that apple added to make it an
even better update if you're currently
paying for an icloud subscription you
can now finally create a custom email
domain for no extra charge at all this
is really awesome for small business
owners because the most popular way to
do this right now is with google
workspace which costs anywhere from six
to eighteen dollars a month so getting
it as a free bonus alongside an icloud
subscription is awesome and making it
even better you don't just get one
custom domain you get up to five custom
domains which is usually enough for a
small business going further icloud
keychain now allows you to add notes
under each password entry which can be
useful if you want to remind yourself
about something about a website or
anything else you want to write down
into the notes section and moving on a
really curious find from steve moser on
twitter is a new cosmetic scan trade-in
tool for the iphone so this will allow
you to do is to find out if your iphone
is actually eligible for trade-in if
you're unsure about any potential damage
being acceptable or not because in the
past you can send in an iphone for
trade-in only to discover that apple
didn't accept it due to cosmetic damage
or cracks but now you'll be able to use
your iphone's camera to scan the front
and the back of your iphone and if it
discovers major issues it'll let you
know that it is not eligible so both you
and apple don't have to waste time and
on top of that apple's trade-in partner
phobio has been getting a lot of
complaints about them secretly damaging
devices to lower trade-in values and
maybe this new feature will allow apple
to confirm that your device was in fact
in good condition when you shipped it
out for trade-in and another good point
is that since apple is now allowing
users to buy apple care up to 60 days
after their purchase they could use this
new cosmetic scan feature to make sure
that it's in good condition first which
will stop users from buying apple care
the second their display cracks to try
and get it covered under warranty now
going further apple has added a pretty
useful little widget for viewing your
apple card balance right from the widget
page so that it's harder to hide the
fact that you've been spending too much
money on apple products recently so yeah
thanks apple and now finally as a little
bonus that not everybody cares about
apple has added in a bunch of new emoji
with ios 15.4 which can come in handy
like the one where you're trying not to
look at your stock portfolio after this
crazy month but all in all i'd have to
say that ios 15.4 is probably the
biggest single update we've seen in a
long time which has single-handedly
fixed a lot of the complaints that
people had about the iphone 13 pro so
hopefully you learned something new from
this video and if you did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and definitely
check out some of those videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]